if we asked ourselves what reasons do we
have to believe in a soul we might start
by asking what means do we have to
believe
both modernism is an eclectic
orientation to the past in a certain
sense it's a return
in many ways the American Revolution
wasn't just a war the war was actually
only a minor part of the American
Revolution the Romans structured a
man-made worldwide Empire out of
architectural forms and exerted a
lasting influence on the architecture
and the architects of post classical
time great literature poetry painting
music they show what human beings can be
the capacity of the human spirit I think
if you come up with good true Christian
theological readings of the New
Testament and you can come up with very
decent historical readings of the New
Testament they just always won't be the
same kind of reading this means that not
only that The Tree of Life connect you
to all the living things on the planet
but the origin of life connections to
the entire universe that's a beautiful
but reading these novels is not just
reading about those things it's also
going to be the process of watching an
artistic form unfold the characteristic
comment on making a real discovery is
not Eureka it's Punk
that's funny
you